a block of medical silicon it actually
sounds like muddy footsteps
surprise
I'm Marcus stemler and I'm Frank Cruz we
are sound designers on the movie All
Quiet on the Western Front
so sound design is like an overall term
for a lot of subdivisions departments
within the sound Department with sound
effects its backgrounds dialogue editing
ADR editing ADR recording and a myriad
of other things but today we'll focus on
the Foley a little bit more
What drew me into sound design really is
the magic you can do you can kind of
steer the focus of the audience I was
drawn to film sound because there were
no rules you creating the opposite of
reality quite often you could do
anything
and right now this film basically are
taking place in mud so there's so many
mighty footsteps from the soldiers and
we really wanted to make sure that all
the math steps they don't sound the same
it's hard to create different sounds if
you just use one technique like the pit
of mud in the on the foli stage the 40
team tried to figure out different ways
to create money footsteps so this is a
block made of medical silicon it's the
stuff you use you know for implants
somehow the 4D Department found out that
if you squeeze it it actually sounds
like muddy footsteps
surprise
foreign
Department was generous enough to give
us a full set of uniforms that you can
see on screen like the actual ones they
used on set including the boots it's
again layers of different elements
because what you definitely don't want
is kind of a form of static sound that
sounds repetitive because then it
becomes fake because everyone knows you
know when you walk down the street your
own footsteps never sound the same
[Music]
there's a scene in a movie where the
starving soldiers grab a goose and make
a stew the sound for the stew they use
very different ingredients
noodles out of rubber or cleaning towels
stuff like that you can see our fully
artists here comes later prepping the
pot and he's using hot water and for
good reason because the sound of cold
and hot water is actually a little bit
different which I could demonstrate
put water first
here comes to hot water
the hot water is way more smooth
and the cold water if you focus on the
top end of it is way more sparkling
and it's a bit more trendy and it's a
sound that everyone knows from breakfast
probably when you pour a tea or a cup of
coffee you kind of instinctively know if
the water is hot or cold but very few
people are conscious about sometimes
when you have to do really quick and
dirty Foley and the Foley artist just
grabs a sip of cold water to simulate
the pouring of a cup of tea you
immediately sense that it's fake but
simply boils down to well pun intended
actually it boils down to the water
being cold
our director wanted a metaphorical sound
for the war machine behind this war the
first industrialized War so I had this
idea about making a sound for the soil
and the dirt and the mud that the
soldiers were trying to avoid to be
turned into I just grabbed a contact
microphone which is a specialized
microphone that just registers
vibrations I just recorded like a bunch
of random movements through sand and
rocks and stone and dirt based on this
metaphorical idea of having the soil and
earth kind of sounding around him while
he's actually trying to survive as Frank
mentioned with this microphone you pick
up vibrations so a great way to to get
an rather abstract sound to put the
microphone
in here
I just drag it around
imagine your body sinking into dirt and
soil it kind of rubbing against your
eardrum so it's kind of being buried
alive essentially
these hearing loss moments there are a
couple in the film usually the first
instinct or it's almost a film cliche is
you muffle everything down and
everything becomes like you're holding
your ears but in this case we went a
little bit against that expectation so
what you hear is the actual close-up
sound of Paul the soldier super dry and
clear and untreated
I must
you hear his close-up breathing in all
the macroscopic details of sand and dust
sprinkling around him it gets you super
close to Paul and his emotions and
connects you immediately to him
another sound we needed frequently in
this film's a sound called a body fall
just people falling onto the ground on
different surfaces so one idea the Foley
guys came up with they made an actual
torso made of ballistic gel the same
amount of ballistic gel weighs exactly
the same as human flesh and has the same
thickness and density and behavior it's
very similar they built this dummy put
Uniforms on it dress it with the helmets
and then we threw it from the roof of
the Foley Studio
foreign so it's a big playground
essentially
we do have a scene where French army is
using flamethrowers and we had some
great recordings from Seth from of
Productions and mixer Victor puzzle in
the scene more famous were added from
wave X and we headed to create more
different layers of flame for us what we
actually recorded was a wheat burner the
folio Department usually uses to when
they start their barbecue they have a
lot of barbecue and so it's always on
standby in this clip we see a great
fully mixer handsome ones like he just
would have everything you could think of
we have a whole Warehouse full of like
five flea markets compressing one a lot
of it is trash
but all these objects are just useful
even if they're just worth one dollar
thing is that they can't see the tanks
first and then all they hear is the
sound and we didn't want to give away
the engine sound it needed to be an
abstract metal sound that connected to
the tanks but it should still be ominous
and mysterious the whole time before
they actually reveal themselves that's
how this idea developed to create like a
iron whale
so talk to the 40 Department and ask
them can you create some groaning metal
sound they went to their warehouse and
they came up with a large part of a
tunnel of the air condition and what you
often can do is if you put a small
object onto a large object they both
make kind of melt into each other so
what they use to trigger the Resonance
of that metal piece was a small toy car
actually
it's a bit ironic because at the end we
kind of use toy cars to add sounds to
tanks
oh
so what happens in the scene when the
tanks are up the surgeons immediately
start firing on them and these tanks are
super resistant against all the bullet
impacts they more or less just tickle
the tanks
there's so many bullet impacts so you
kind of want to create a variation of
them so they don't just sound all the
same the 40 guys just set up a little
drumming session we just use those
sounds and layer them to create a bit of
a variety
foreign
recycling Montage at the beginning of
the film there's this transition where
in the sewing machine workshop and you
hear like first all the sewing machines
during you know everyone working it cuts
to the close-up of the needle and then
the needle slowly transitions into a
machine gun
who had wanted that sequence to reflect
like the war machine that I talked about
the industry behind the war and so all
these images are essentially symbols for
that
[Music]
I also always loved the way of kind of
sonically verbalizing what sad history
is attached to that very uniform
connecting the set past with the most
likely future
thanks so much for your interest in our
work and I think look at some of the
secrets of the sound design of this film
thank you everyone with good fun thank
you for having us
thanks JQ and this part